last time we chatted with him his
pockets were a little lighter than they
are now and a very well-deserved
contract extension and a new teammate to
help rush the passer in this
pass-heavy quarterback heavy division
the
las vegas raiders pro bowl and all pro
defensive end max crosby back here on
the rich island show how are you doing
max
i'm doing great brother thank you uh
thank you for having me on you got it
absolutely so we couldn't help but
notice on wednesday's
program towards the end of our show
uh we saw the tweet with all the googly
eyes from your twitter account
that was to promote the fact that you
were coming on this show right max all
those googlies absolutely
absolutely just want to make sure
make sure
uh at least that's what we thought um
and then about 20 minutes later we heard
the news that chandler jones was coming
to vegas so you could be honest with me
shoot me straight what were they
i was
elated uh when i found out the news um
you know chandler is uh
he's like a big brother to me it's it's
kind of crazy um i honestly i had no
idea that any of this was in the works
um
and you know once once i found out i
freaking lost my mind because chandler's
you know he's always been one of those
guys
that i can call and talk to about about
football about you know anything
so
i've always been a
huge chandler jones fan i love his game
i love the way he plays
he's a future hall of famer so
once i got the news we immediately
called each other and we're freaking
going nuts on the phone and uh we're
just fired up man so um
what what give me a little bit more on
that relationship what did you first
meet him and and and what do you mean by
that he's someone you can call and talk
to any time what about them
yeah so um you know we we linked up a
while back um because we trained with
some of the same people
um and co and coach buckner coached him
in arizona so we know each other through
that as well
um so we always kind of
you know i've always been like a big fan
you know i looked at him as you know
just a great player somebody i wanted to
be like so i always try to you know pick
his brain at first and just ask
questions and then it kind of turned to
a you know a better relationship we
always stayed in contact and i was just
asking him you know about certain
situations like
this past year i was going on like a
sack slump i felt like i was playing my
best football but i couldn't for some
reason i wasn't getting sex and you know
just reaching out to him about things
like that and how he handled it um and
you know just bouncing things off him
because he's done it at a high level for
so long and it's somebody i aspire to be
like
so just having those conversations and
him being in my corner um is awesome so
yeah when i found out the news like
we're on the same wavelength so we
literally text each other at the same
time
and we're freaking losing our mind so we
we hopped on facetime and we had a great
talk and you know he's super excited and
yeah we're just ready to get to work i
bet i bet so because you're tight i'm
assuming you follow him on twitter
because you know he's very sensitive as
to who follows him and who doesn't
um you know he even called kyler murray
out for that sort of thing so i'm sure
you're right you guys are all locked up
there okay just want to make sure about
that
and i'm telling you i mean because now
you got russell wilson in your division
man and this is the deepest uh
quarterback uh division we've seen
certainly in the afc last time that all
four starters were had a pro bowl under
their belt
to start a season in the same division
in the afc was the 2012 afc west that's
a nugget that i saw through nfl network
research so clearly that is important to
get as many pass rushes as possible
going i'd imagine yeah absolutely you
know obviously with free agencies
starting you know everybody um
you know it's been kind of quiet on on
the raider side of things people are
like tweeting at me come on max recruit
come on we got to get things going we
got you know the broncos got russell the
chargers got khalil
and you know people are freaking out but
you know today i think was a was a big
day um for raider nation so you know i'm
i'm super fired up and obviously
the quarterbacks in our division are
ridiculous you know if you got
arguably you got three
you got two young superstars you got
derek carr who's an established pro
bowler you got freaking russell wilson
who's going to be
you know arguably in the hall of fame
it's incredible but that's what you play
for like at the end of the day that's
what i want to play against
it gets me fired up
it pushes me every day even more to
improve just continue getting better
raiders defensive end max crosby here on
the rich eisen show
so last we spoke um you were you know it
was fresh off of the season ender uh
against cincinnati and you were pounding
the table
for rich versace to get the job
full-time as we know
he is not the full-time head coach it's
josh mcdaniels now your new hc how does
how did that all sit with you and how
does everything clearly uh work out for
you we know contract-wise but just about
the fact that the coach that the the
team was really into and and and rallied
around is is not the guy that they
eventually landed on max
yeah you know that's that's the tough
part about this business is that
you're never gonna be you're never gonna
get whatever you know everything you
want you know at the end of the day we
all love rich everybody in that locker
room loves rich
um
but it's a part of this business you
know at the end of the day as a player
you can't control everything um i could
only get my piece um so i just shared my
truth you know about rich and how i felt
um you know but things went the other
way you know zay jones another guy i
love zay jones of death one of the best
teammates i've had and he's you know he
decided to go somewhere else as well so
it's like at the end of the day you just
gotta you know hold people in high
regard
um
and wish him the best at the end of the
day rich will always be in my corner i
know zay will be in my corner i know
yannick um you know yannick got traded
to uh the colts as well and that's like
that's like a brother to me so i'm
always have love for him so that's just
a part of this business you're never in
full control and um you just got to
continue to improve every single day so
that's that's my goal and you know i
just i got you know i'm always have a
ton of love for all those guys well what
can you tell me again you're not in the
building yet right i mean
the cba prevents being in the building
in terms of
you know so on and so forth um full-time
getting in playbooks or what have you
but what about the new
regime certainly on your side of the
ball can you tell raiders fans about how
things might be different than previous
yeah you know i i don't want to correct
you but i i've i've been in the building
not bad the day after super bowl i've
been training
well i guess i guess i guess i mean in
the playbooks and things of that nature
i should have said yeah no
for sure um yeah you know obviously
being around the new staff just kind of
building the relationship first has been
super important obviously we're all new
to each other um so yeah i'm always
there
um
and i always run into them and to have
great conversations so
um you know they're in it for the same
reasons at the end of the day they want
to win football games and they want to
you know bring a ring
or multiple rings to las vegas so
coach mcdaniels coach graham you know
rob ryan being there
um coach oakland there's so many new
guys um but we're just building those
relationships um we could watch film
talk
talk football
you know just just go over everything
because at the end of the day the
relationships are what matter most so
um we're just building those um feelings
stronger every day and you know i think
i think we got a great group of coaches
you know who are coming in and ready to
you know change this thing around and
then patrick graham you mentioned the
new defensive coordinator how different
the defense do you think it's going to
be the difference between last year and
this yeah you know uh coach graham i've
known him since i since i got in the
league he
we had a great interview when i was
getting ready for the draft
and he was like
super positive and
he's uh it was funny he was so positive
and so like
nice to me and like man i love the way
you play
and at that time i was you know not
people didn't really think that highly
of me i had you know i was coming from
eastern i was like 240 pounds
and hearing him talk like so positively
i thought he was like being sarcastic
and like nothing with me
but
you know
if we ended up you know whatever the
interview went you know how it went i
called my age i'm like i don't know if
this he was messing with me or not but
he didn't say one negative thing
and
i end up you know fast forward i end up
seeing you know patrick graham hired his
raiders d coordinator and i immediately
got a call from him and he's like man
you remember our interview oh my god man
i love i love your game i'm so excited
to coach you i'm like damn that's crazy
so it's just wild but as far as the
scheme of things um he likes to run a
lot of different things and he bases it
off the personnel so you know he's a
great coach um he's proven that but i
think he's going to put us in the best
position to be successful
and and this on a scale of zero to uh
certifiably insane how crazy is rob ryan
um
is he's my kind of guy
he's my kind of guy he's hilarious
and he's you know he loves football and
he's every single day he's always
he's always walking through hey max
what's up man i got a little cutoff for
you got some brian kerrigan this week
you got some other stuff and i'm always
asking him to make stuff for me as well
so he's a he's a great dude i was just
with him today well he he a couple of
years ago uh he spent some time on nfl
network during the playoffs as a guest
uh analyst i think we had to provide him
a tie and shoes i think that had to come
from our wardrobe department that's how
he showed up like open-toed sandals and
in no time we're like okay coach this is
your you i think that happened
i'm trying to yeah that's one thing i
respect he's always going to do him
i fully respect it no doubt about that
max crosby here on the rich eisen show
um and then the last time we spoke um
you did not have your long-term contract
extension and i wish you a hearty
congratulations on that sir
um you know 95 million bucks a whole
bunch of new money a whole bunch of
guaranteed money and i follow you on
twitter uh at crosby max um two x's and
i saw a photograph that you had tweeted
out uh on the
the 11th of march
it's your right hand on the steering
wheel with the date
of 3 11 20 on your thumb
and you said today is a special day two
years sober and then i saw on your
twitter account just a few hours later a
photograph of you smiling and signing a
new contract with that very same hand
and it blew me
away that on your two-year sober
anniversary you hit it with a long-term
contract and i'm wondering how that
landed with you max crosby
yeah you know uh
it's funny because the night before um
the night before is when i got the news
um
that we were locked in you know we we
had been going back and forth for a
little while
and we finally got to a point where
we were comfortable they were
comfortable
and you know we we got to we got it done
so i knew that next day
i was going to be signing and everything
like that um and it's just crazy how it
works you know the timing of it is like
you know you can't make it up so
um it was just
you know i went in there early in the
morning to go work out and then you know
i knew i was about to
sign my contract that day so it's just
it's just crazy how the timing of thing
goes and you know just doing the right
thing at the end of the day like that's
what that represents to me like two
years
two years ago i was literally in a
in a car on my way to la you know to get
sober go to a rehab facility like and
two years later i'm
almost made a hundred million dollars
you know got a 100 million dollar
contract which is like
it's bizarre you know just it just shows
you you know like if you do the right
things consistently and put your you
know right foot forward it's like
it's unbelievable where you can go and
it just it's exciting for me because i
know it's just the beginning and like
i'm i'm so far from where i want to be
um which is
you know a hall of famer i want to be a
lot of you know i want to be a great
player you know the money
you know kobe talked about all the time
like money's always
money is never should be your motivation
because once you get the money then
you're not playing for anything
so like for me i
at the end of the day i'm playing for
the love of it and you know coach
marinelli talks about all the time like
having that childish love for the game
and
that's just for me it's like i feel like
a kid you know obviously the money
money's amazing but if i play the right
way and continue to take care of myself
the way i'm doing i'm gonna make more
money than i ever imagined so
um it's just a blessing man it's uh
super super exciting my family my my
fiance everybody's all excited and you
know i'm just doing what i do show up
early in the morning get to work and you
know keep keep pushing forward if you
don't mind me asking you could uh not
answer if you don't want but what what
caused you to get in the car that day on
the 20th the uh the 11th of march 2020.
what caused you to get in that car to go
to los angeles max
um
you know
at first i didn't i didn't want to get
in the car um
and that's that's the scary part about
you know that disease you know the
disease i have you know addiction is
is no joke um
and i was at my last my last straw like
i couldn't
i was at the point where
just mentally physically i was so
drained that i you know i knew i didn't
want to get in the car i didn't want to
go to rehab but i knew i literally had
to um and that's kind of what it was for
me i looked myself in the mirror and was
like
i need help like there's no other way i
got to get help and
without the people around me as with the
team my my from my agent to my mentors
from you know to my fiance
all the people around me like without
them
you know it wouldn't be possible so
there's so many people i can you know
give credit to but yeah you know the
main reason was just you know it was it
was time you know to stop living that
way
um
and just change change what i had going
on
and if i told you as you got in that car
hey
the the decision you're making right now
is going to lead to two years from now
you signing uh damn near a nine figure
contract because
it's going to unlock
the talent in you what would you have
said
max
i don't i don't know you know honestly
it's
i would have
looking back it didn't even seem real
you know for me
you know looking back for for these two
years
has been what 300 or close to 700 days
or whatever a little over 700 days
like the amount of footwork that i've
had to do to get to this point
is insane and the the exciting part is
that it's only been two years like i
have so much more room to grow
i'm still growing into my body i'm still
i'm still 24 years old i'm young
and got so much more to look forward to
so
yeah it's just it's just a blessing you
know not not only for me but my kids
my future kids everybody's gonna be
you know taken care of so it's just you
know it's that extra security um that's
that's amazing so yeah i'm just i'm just
looking forward to the next one i'm
gonna win some more rings and that's
that's that's the ultimate goal yeah i
got to tell you i just saw those tweets
just a few hours apart and it blew me
away i really didn't i'm like you know
what i got to ask him next time he comes
on
about uh about that day and what at the
significance of that day and two years
apart and really you know because we
talk about this sort of subject matter
on this show all the time max is what it
means to so many people
to see how making these decisions and
sticking with it and it being very
difficult i'm sure for you as a
professional athlete
being around you know uh
uh spirits if you will you know and and
in las vegas my gosh you know and how
it's paid off literally figuratively
it's so cool it is so cool max it's so i
appreciate it
you are very welcome um so congrats on
that and uh what what does the next few
weeks look like for you
walk me through what the next few weeks
for you business as usual um
that day like the day after i signed i
was in the building super early in the
morning getting after it so
um i'm in full training mode i've been
for
almost a month and a half now so yeah
just just working and getting ready for
ota all right you're gonna be there
around the draft i'm coming to town you
know i'm coming to town absolutely i'll
be seeing you for sure okay i will be
there uh
the nfl drafts coming to las vegas
nevada i hope to see you and and shake
that hand that you signed the uh the
contract with and we'll we'll do this
again sometime soon congrats on that and
uh i look forward to seeing you in just
a couple weeks yes sir thank you so much
i appreciate you brother always always
that is pro bowl defensive end and all
pro at the position max crosby right
here on the rich eisen show hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here